was that yeah what's the your your best
and also worst experience while on
mushrooms because I I dabble in the
shrooms a bit myself I'll tell you what
I I've never had a bad one on mushrooms
but on acid you had a bad Acid Trip yes
what happened I was in a studio it was
me my boy CB were recording for the
Harvard dropout
and I'm taking a piss in a bathroom
and then the whole toilet starts turning
black like in a circle and it just
starts closing I'm like oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] I put my pants up I start running
in the studio and I piss on myself wow
like oh [ __ ] you pulled your pants up
while you're pissing I put my pencil
while I'm pissing because the whole
toilet started closing on me like it was
like big black hole just closing I'm
like oh [ __ ] Jesus Christ my pants about
start running I'm like
and I come back to the studio I'm like
[ __ ] I just pissed on myself
[Laughter]
that was like one of the weirdest
yeah the thing about acid is like really
visual like shrooms can be visual but
they're also like they also like just
have you deep deeply stuck in your
thoughts last time I did it was Sunday
service
the last time either shrooms yeah want
to go see yeah yeah um Coachella on
Sunday service so you went to Coachella
shroomed out well no one acid oh an acid
yeah I was like [ __ ] eight in the
morning wow I was just [ __ ] tweaking
I'm like that's the last time I do this
was that the only drug you were on
because 8 A.M [ __ ] 8am man that [ __ ]
will keep you up yeah